we're not going to do that we're moving
on to women in our own country there's a
new show out
hillary clinton chelsea clinton
it's called gutsy
and it's about women who are brave
and i you know me
often at the end of a long day
when i have done everything i've done
i've
made people laugh i've dealt with my
incompetent employees my
uh horrific
agents and
managers and people
that are impediments to my success when
i'm done navigating
that
i come home
and i turn on the tv
and i i i say where are the brave
women to watch
wha why are there not more
because these
these women that the clintons have
chosen a spotlight are gutsy
apparently not all women are gutsy but
some of the these women are
and many of these gutsy women are also
very wealthy and famous
which is interesting
i don't know
so hillary
one of the episodes is with a
white an ex-white
supremacist did you know that i did not
know that hillary clinton
our real president
speaks with an ex-white supremacist on
the show
gutsy and there's a clip of that
somewhere
where this woman
is happy
to because now what the ex-white
supremacist does
she goes around the country trying to
get other people
to stop being hateful
i think that's what she claims to do
and hillary
is very impressed by this
and hillary
and this woman it's an unlikely
kinship
they have so do you
are you finding anything about this i'm
finding this article on yahoo right now
i'm going through it yeah it's it's
beautiful and i don't you i'm not you i
don't usually fall for this type of
emotional stuff but it is kind of
beautiful
uh yeah shannon foley martinez a former
white supremacist from georgia who uses
commute canoe trips down the broad river
to help rehabilitate women leaving hate
groups canoe trips yes so if you're in a
hate group
she shows up with the canoe goes get in
this canoe you nazi [ __ ]
and then she you go down the river with
her i like this yeah what a good
business only in america
can you have a business
putting nazis in a canoe
and trying to get them to hate jews less
it's a
there's economic opportunity everywhere
so this woman who used to be a in a hate
group
now she's in a canoe
hillary clinton
and her
now do you do you have i i there's a
clip of this let's let's find this clip
and it's this woman
talking about how grateful she is
to have been
contacted by
hillary clinton our secretary
of um
hate groups
francis i'm going to send this to you
it's it's it's beautiful i like this
they paint with megan the stallion
hillary and chelsea clinton you'd think
they'd go away at some point the
clintons but they don't
they never go away
they're in their mid
hundreds
they're both fat now
they're walking around the hamptons and
she's like wearing a big frock
looks like she's in a big painting smock
bill's just out of it because he's a he
had a heart thing he can't [ __ ] he's got
no
he doesn't want to live anymore because
he can't [ __ ] he's a vegan
he looks dead he looked like he died
years ago and he always has that weird
look on his face like he's in the middle
of a stroke and he's walking down the
beach
with his morbidly obese elderly wife
that daughter
they have and a few secret service
people
and they're in the hamptons and they're
just kind of like
just the last few days
the last few hours
and no one really cares anymore and now
they're just kind of like in the
entertainment business like the obamas
and really like donald trump's always
been in the entertainment business but
like when you leave office in america
you just go right into the entertainment
business you start producing
documentaries and tv shows the obamas
how to deal with netflix and now
hillary's doing this show gutsy you just
become
part of the uh entertainment big stars
big stars on the show but who's on the
show they're big stars you got uh goldie
hawn
yes cat a cat hudson is it is that a
kate kate hudson kate hudson you got amy
schumer yeah gutsy kim kardashian guts
brave wanda psychics
brave guts megan the stallion i liked
that they didn't go with nurses
teachers in bad areas i like that no i
like it
because we i'm i'm happy that they're
not pretending to care about those
people because no one really does
so everybody just wants to see like
what's goldie hawn been up to no one
wants to see a teacher from detroit
what i'm happy that hillary didn't go
the route of like let's spotlight
non-famous
non-celebrity women who have balls who
are gutsy who are brave who are making a
difference let's find
celebrities
multi-millionaires
and shove them down people's throats and
tell regular people
how brave amy schumer is
how hard it is to be amy schumer how
difficult it is to live in martha's
vineyard and how gutsy you are to take
the private plane to martha's vineyard i
like that
i think it's good is there anyone
regular on the show besides the is the
one non-celebrity the ex-nazi [ __ ] uh i
watched the first episode because it's
free on apple tv okay yeah apple tv they
they do talk to um
uh some some comedians in the show okay
not any i'm not high high level
comedians uh so uh no but no no no
layman type of a man how about a female
cop
that i did not did they leave out a
female cop so here's what i would say if
i'm thinking of gutsy female jobs right
just off the top of my head you're a
[ __ ] and you're out there working
what's a gutsy job i think cop
female cop right because men have a
physical advantage in strength sure
true
maybe a mental advantage in certain
capacities not gonna comment on it i'm
not a doctor
the point is i don't know i'm just
saying
you're a
if you're a a cop which is a horrible
job anyway reserved mainly for uh stupid
and aggressive people can we say that
dumb and aggressive people for the most
part become police you need police but
it's not the best and brightest sorry if
you're a cop and you're listening to
this you know i'm right they're like
it's like a backyard wrestling kind of
you know
animal or something that usually becomes
a cop the most of the people i know
who are police were literally criminals
up until the moment they decided to
become police literally like the weekend
before
and a lot of during training
uh during uh what do they call that uh
when you go into the police academy yeah
when you're in the academy they were
still kind of criminals
right up until graduate like and some of
them are just criminals cops drive drunk
they they commit crimes really they do
but that being said because it's not a
celebration of the police
what we're saying is that of a female
cop it's a ballsy job but i guess
there's something uh that
hillary just doesn't want
to to highlight a female cop no
she doesn't want to do it she doesn't
want to do it so we're not going to make
her do it but that would have been
interesting to me like like if you said
a female gutsy job let's say a cop
or maybe a teacher in the inner city
like dangerous minds remember michelle
pfeiffer in the movie dangerous minds
where a
white woman went into a school you want
to talk about the most racist movie ever
a white woman
went into a school and the only way she
could deal with minorities was to be
like a marine
and remember like that first
first scene in the movie she's like
she like people are trying to fight her
all the time remember that and she's
just like she's constantly in a stance
and they were like dangerous minds
and then she came in and she took them
all out to a restaurant and they're like
yo what's the filet mignon
and she's like it's a steak
remember that
that was like one of the original white
savior movies dangerous michelle but
that i would think ballsy
female the job uh
teacher in the inner city
cop
so do we have this clip of this white
supremacy this is actually kind of
beautiful francis was that it in that
article because she left that
you know movement of hate and
discrimination uh to try to you know
live a different life and she's now
trying to reprogram others to help them
get um
beyond all of that but more than that
we're looking for women who are gutsy
not just on behalf of themselves but on
behalf of others we had two-way
conversations with the women we were
interviewing but we kind of want a
two-way conversation with people
watching it and we hope it sparks a lot
of conversations in in families and in
you know groups of friends and everybody
else secretary clinton speaking of that
give and take you interview a reverend
in the rebel hearts episode where you
open up about one of the gutsiest
decisions you've had to make in your
life which was the decision to stay in
your marriage
you have a marriage that has been on
public display since the beginning you
said the gutsiest thing you ever did was
stay in your marriage that doesn't mean
that's right for everybody why did you
want to open up about that and the
reason
she goes the reason that i stayed in my
marriage
is because my husband was the president
of the united states
now that's not right for everybody
because many people's husbands are not
the president of the united states but
she goes me and my husband
we've killed people together we have
many many shady financial deals
we are blackmailing several people we
run essentially a criminal crime
syndicate together so it's more than
just
a marriage
but
i don't i you know listen go watch that
show gutsy